アビダンマとして我々はずっと徹底的に分析論を喋っていたんですね
で 人間にとっては物事を本当は分析して分析して分けて分けて分けて分けて分けていった方が
あの 何か理解するのは簡単な方法なんです
で それにもう一つ理由があって
我々の理解っていうのは
物事をまとめてまとめてまとめて理解するということになってるんです
普通の人間の理解の過程っていうのは
で 예를言えば 例えば花を植えたとすると
やっぱりそちらに美しさはないんです
本当は でも我々はいろんなことをまとめて
あの器やら花の立て方やら形やら角度やら花の色やら葉っぱの色やら
また背景やら そういうものを全部まとめて
ああ すごい綺麗やと思っちゃうんですね
で まあ料理にしたっても同じことなんですね
いろんなものをまとめたところでおいしいものだと思っちゃうんですね
誰でもジャガイモを生でそのままかじることはしないんですね
で ですから 私達の知識過程というのは
そういう風に まあいろんなものの働きをいくらかそれなりにまとめて新しいものができた時
それを理解すると で また違う例で言うと
例えば水というのは誰でも知ってるし
水っていうのはまあ本当かどうか分かりませんだけど
科学では酸素水素でできているんだと言ってるんですね
で 我々には酸素水素なんかなかなか理解しにくいんだけど
まあ水としては簡単に理解できるんですね
で 問題は酸素と水素もまるっきり別な性格を持っている
液体ではなくてガスなんですね
で 液体ではいられないし
それから働きは随分違うんですね
まあ酸素が重くて水素がすごく軽くてとかね
で 酸素はもう何でもかんでも破壊するんであって
水素はものちょっとしたことで
まあ引火してもう燃えてしまうとか
いろいろまあまるっきり別々な性格のものなんですけど
私たちが知ってる水っていうのは
やっぱりまとめたところ出ていることで
またまるっきり別なものなんですね
ですから このまとめて理解するということは
全く別なものを理解しているということになっちゃうんですね
で 水を知っている人は決して水素酸素のことを知っているわけじゃないんです
ですから この世の中で
人間のどんな生命にも
理解っていうのは物事をまとめて新しい現象ができたところで出てくる理解なんですね
ですから 本物の理解はまあかなり違うというふうになります
そういうわけで 最初に仏教では
この人間の無明に無知の壁を破るために提案しているのは
じゃあ分析しましょうと
で とことん分析すると
で それにはこのこれはある部派仏教の話ではないかと思うかもしれませんだけど
本当はそうではなくて
お釈迦様の初期的な初期時代のお釈迦様自身の説法の中でも
何でもかんでも やっぱりできるだけ分析するんですね
アビダンマみたいに もうきめ細かく分析しようとはしてないんだけど
まあそれなりに人間が理解できるところまでは分析しているんですね
まあ五蘊というものを我々は知っているし
で 何とか16相ですか
18界とかね まあそういう分析は昔からあったもので
で 煩悩はそれなりに分析しているし
まあこれこれこれこういうものだと
で 執着というものは まあやたら人々は執着という言葉を使ってますからね
仏教だけではなくて どんな宗教でも
それでお釈迦様はそんな以外の執着という言葉を使うな
執着はいくつあるかと
それは一つ一つどういう働きがあるかと
それちゃんと言わなきゃよくないんだと
例えばそういうところで
まああの批判するんですね
ですから やっぱりお釈迦様が物事を分析したところで
真理を見えてくる 真理を見えてくると言ったっても
今まで真実だと思ったものはそうではないと分かっていくんですね
それで次に自分出会うものをまた分析すると
それもそうではなかったと
そこでまあ究極的に分析していく
それで あ そうではなかった
そうではなかったということで
知恵が発達していくんですね
だからここで立派な人間がいるんだと誰でも思っている
それで色受想行識に分けてみたら
まあどこら辺に人間いるか人間消えてしまっちゃうんですね
で そんなものはなかったと後でわかる
分析の結果なんですね
それからじゃあ色ってなんですかで言えば
ただの物質ですから それと世の中にある物質ともう全然変わりがない
それは自分でもないし
自分の魂でもないし 我でもないし
我のものでもなくなっちゃうんです
ただの物質ですからね
物質の法則を見ると それは無常であると分かってしまうし
人間の感情感覚を見ても同じことで
それ感情自体私ではないし
感情はずっと変化していくんだと
ですからその感情は私の魂でもないんだと
それでまあ それはそうではないということになってしまっちゃう
そこで五蘊を見たところで私がいないと
大体悟るためにはそれぐらいの分析はすごい十分なんですね
で 自我というものはないことを理解するために
何か掴まるものはないと
で 人間は何ものにもとらわれてはいけないということを理解して体験するためには
やっぱり五蘊の分析 色受想行識という
その分析では十分ですけど
で それで結局全ては無常であって変化していくんだと
変化するものはそれなりの因縁によって変化していくんだということが見えてきます
それでだんだん心が諦めがついて
何か探そう探そうと 何か芯を
何て言いますか ものの芯というか
ものの魂のような実体のようなものは探そうという気持ちがもう消えてしまっちゃうんで
それ探そうと自体が無知なる行動だと
無意味だと 見つかりようがないんだということで諦めがつけて
そこで解脱するという心が生まれてくるんです
で そういうことで ずっと仏教ではまあまとめるって考えるのではなくて
分析して考えちゃうんですね
で 昔は私は子供の時はいろいろ人の話を聞いていた時は
今は人の話を聞きませんだから
昔はまあ結構人の話は聞きましたし
性格はできてた時に悪くなったのは最近ですね
で あの まあこういうふうなことを言われたんですね
あんたはね まあもう何ても日の出の時とかね
あるいは日没の時とかね
空を見てくださいと いかに美しいかと
で そういうふうにこの
こんなものは人間に作られますかと
こんなに巨大な それなりの美しさって自然を見てくださいと
いかに美しくてしっかりできているのではないかと
ですから それは人間には作られませんと
故にそれは全ては神が作ったものだと
だから神っていうのはそうそう異常なものだと
人間にはそうそうできないんだと
で そういうふうに教えてもらったところはありますけどね
で こちらの頭には これはもうできているものを見て
まとめたものを見て またそれはそのままそれで認めて
違う形而上学的な概念を正当化していることだけではないかと
たとえ虹が綺麗だと思ったら
どこに虹があるんですかね
それはただの目の錯覚であって
だから私はそんなにあるんだったら捕まってみようと
小さい時はね まあわざわざ弟と一緒に水をいろいろ流してみたりとかね
毎日一年中太陽があるんだから
もう簡単に作られますからね
で 水の中でも現れますから
なんて大したことはないんだと
だから分析してみると
そこはもう別に大したことはないし
プリズムですか ガラスを通って光が曲がって
もらっても同じく虹が出てくるし
だからただ光が曲がる
それだけのことで そちらに神秘性も聖なるものも神も誰もいるわけじゃないんですね
だから やっぱり分析してみた方がよろしいし
科学の世界でもなぜそこまで発展していったかというと
ものが分析してみるんですね
それでもののありさまがわかってくるということ
ですから 今まではそういうことですごい厳密に分析して
分析して それから分析したものをいろんなカテゴリーに入れて
それぞれの働き 同じものでもあろうが
自分 あの いろんな場所でいろんな働きをしてしまう
ですから そういうところも理解してほしいと
例えば例えばサティという言葉
念という言葉ありまして
サティというのはたった個体的な一つのものというよりは
そのそのいろんな働きをしてくれるんだと
ですから この同じ項目が厳密に分析でならばなぜダブっているかとという問題も出てきますからね
例えば五つの力がありますいうたら
そこでサティが入っていて
修行には根元みたいに支えてくれる根元が五つありますといったところで
そこにまたサティが入ってあったりとかね
ですからサティそのものも
その場で時々は修行を支えてくれる根っこみたいな強いものである
時々修行に修行に力をつけてくれるものになるとか
で いろんな働きをしてくれますし
そういうことでいろんなカテゴリーに入ります
ですから 一番たくさんカテゴリーに入るのはパンニャ
智慧なんですね それは力にも入るし
五根にも入るし 八正道にも入るし
もう入らないところはないほど
だから大変ないろんな働きをしてくれると
そういうところも分析の世界で理解していかなくちゃいけないんですね
それからまあ ただ分析しただけで
またもうちょっと理解が足らないところがありますね
で このまとめることですか
アナリシスだけではなくて
シンテシスですか どのように物事を一緒に組み合わせて
まるっきり今までなかった新しい現象を作りますかと
で そこら辺も理解しなくちゃいけないんですね
で それは大変な仕事なんです
分析ほどは簡単ではないんです
なぜならば 何が何かと一緒になってどうにどうなるかということは
これはもう大変な世界なんですね
これは現象の世界だから
現象にはキリがないんですね
で 虹にしたってもまるっきりどこでも同じく虹が現れるということがないしね
その時その時の環境において虹の形が変わっちゃうし
薄く見える場合もあるし
しっかりと派手に明確に見える時もあるし
だから子供たちが水遊びしてする時はもうそれなりの小さく出てくるし
ですから 今 現代的な光やら光のいろんな曲がり
曲がり方 いろいろ機械作ってでも虹を作られますからね
そうすると虹の数っていうのは数えられなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから このこうこうすればこういう風な虹が出ますよと
こうこうすればこんな感じの虹が出ますよと
これはもう意味がない
いくら言ったっても で
料理も同じことで 材料はほとんど決まっていて
そんなたくさんあるわけじゃないんだけど
それもまとめることによって
もういろんな料理あるでしょうに
それはだから料理勉強する人にとっては一生かかっても終わらないんですね
日本和食を徹底的にプロになってやろうと思ったら
それに一生かかってしまっちゃうし
その人にはまた勉強しなくちゃいけないこと
西洋の料理やら中国的な料理やら
もういろんなありますからね
そういうものを勉強しようと思ったら
もう寿命が足りなくなっちゃうんですね
それほどたくさんある
じゃあそれで終わっちゃいますかと
じゃあ和食はそれで一定にもう固定していますか？そうでもないし
それから新しい和食の新しい考え方が出てきて
新しい料理を作ることはそれからもういくらでも可能なんですね
いくらでも可能なんです
ですから 例えば大根料理だったらこれしかないんだと数えられて言えますかね
言えません で 今まであるものは数えられますけど
じゃあ新しいの作り方はないかというと
それはないわけじゃなくて
あるんですね ですから
現象の世界っていうのはもうキリがない
いくら見たっても それで全てということにはならない
そういうわけで それはまとめ論なんですね
合成論なんですね 大根料理にしたっても
どのように何をと合成するかということで大根料理成り立ちますからね
ですから そういうのは合成論で合成論になっちゃうと
人にはやりきれなくなっちゃうんです
そこでどこまでやったっても
それで何か大した意味がありますか？と
もう大した意味がないんですね
例えば ある人が大根料理を
全て自分でもうこれから現れる料理も全部自分でやってみるんだと
で やってみたっても ありとあらゆる料理方法でやってみるとかね
それで意味がありますか？とね
それで もう一人の人がまたそれで違う方法でやったならば
違う料理になってしまうし
ですから 一番簡単なのは
もう料理方法なんであろうと
そもそもあなたが食べてるのは大根でしょうと
ただそれだけの これは西洋的なソースかけて食べたって
もう醤油かけて食べたって
結局食べてるのは大根でしょうということで
まあ物事はうまくまとまっちゃうんですね
ですから やっぱり分析論には力を入れます
で 合成論には力は入れません
入れないのは これはキリがないんだからなんですね
だから ただ頭が狂ってしまっちゃうだけで
そういうわけで この合成論になると
お釈迦様はこれだけはとても難しいんだと
わかりにくいんだと これ理解しないんだから
人間がもう苦しみを終えなくて
輪廻転生し続けているんだと
で 合成論だけはもう軽々く簡単だと思ってはいけませんと
だから軽々しいものではないんですね
だから まあそれでも欲があるんだから簡単に理解したいと
わかりやすく言ってくれとかね
いうのは人間の希望なんですけど
そういう希望が生まれたら大根に例えてみてください
世の中で大根料理はいくつありますか？と
それで全てですか？それ以上大根料理はありませんかと
作れませんか？と そうするとそれにはキリがないと
知っても何の意味もないということもわかるはずなんですね
そういうわけで この仏教では因果論になる
因果論なんですけど この合成論なんですけど
この合成論になると ありったけのことを説明しようとはしてないんです
一番まあまあ集中して説明しているのは
どのように苦しみが生まれますかと
人間の苦しみ あるいは
輪廻でもよろしいし なぜ生まれてきますかということですね
まあそれと同時に どうすればこの合成やってる過程をね
どのように変化すればその苦しみが消えますかと
ただその一つのポイントに絞ってるんです
で 他のものについてお釈迦様は
興味ないと 興味ないというよりは無意味だと
私は苦しみと苦しみから解脱脱出する方法しか喋れませんと
知っていても喋ったっても役に立ちませんだからね
そういうことでお話はしていない
そこでこのアビダンマ
アビダンマの世界ではこの合成論も二種類にまた分けているんですね
で 経典にはそんなに二種類に分けてないんです
ただ 簡単に言ってますからね
その二種類はパティッチサムッパードナヤ
パッターナナヤ なんですけど
日本語ではどんな言葉になるんですかね
演技の仕方 所縁論の仕方と
まあそこもわかりませんね
で 次にはその説明はありますけど
それもわかりませんと書いてあるの
まあ一応パーリ語ではパティッチサムッパードナヤ
パッキャ パッターナ パティッチサムッパードナヤ
パッターナナヤという 2つなんですね
で パティッチサムッパードというのは縁起という意味でパティッチサムッパード
パティッチャっていうのはいろんな原因によりまして
サムッパードっていうのは生起しますよと
原因によって生まれますよ
生起しますよという意味で
その法則 方法 ですから
縁起の仕方ですね で パッターナっていうのはやっぱりもうちょっと違って条件のことで
パッターナっていうのはあの何に支え支えられてというぐらいの意味なんですね
環境のことなんですね
どのどんな環境の中で
どんな条件の中で その上にいた縁起が生まれますかと
ということで ちょっと難しいんですけど
わかりやすく言うなればこういうことなんですね
原因と結果ということは一番我々にはわかりやすい
そこでもう一つ考えてるんですね
原因と結果ではなくて
そのその原因がいろいろ条件によって結果が出すんだと
だから条件というのは結局原因ではない
ということは この原因があっても確実に結果が出るということではないと
という風に もうちょっと 2つに分けてみたことだけなんですね
でもよく考えると原因結果だけで十分ですけど
条件というものはいろいろ疑問にはなりますが
アビダンマのテーラワーダアビダンマでも
それもあんまりしっかりしてないんです
原因論 因縁条件論というのはしっかりしてないんだけど
一番大きなアビダンマテキストなんです
ものすごい分厚くて でもうややこしくて読むとこはもうまるっきり無理ですね
であれほど大きく書いてるんだけど
やっぱりしっかりまだ成り立ってないんです
で 原因の結果のことを分かりやすく理解
なぜこれ 2つに分けたかと
原因結果だけ言わないで
なぜ条件論も喋ってますか？ということは
我々はもうそういう批判して勉強するとこじゃなくて
多分基本的なことを勉強するとこだけですから
そこら辺言いますけど
まあ例えば人を見る 遠く遠く人がこちら向かってくるのを見て
私たちは綺麗な人ですよと決めてしまう
そこで人が原因で綺麗な人だという感情が生まれたことは結果なんですね
そこでその人はどんどんどんどん違ってくる
違ってきたら まああの感情が随分変わってしまう
綺麗ではなくて なんでもう変な人ではないかと
顔がもうしわだらけで
いろいろもうどうああだこうだとかね
服はまあ全然もうダメだと
髪の毛も全然綺麗じゃないとかね
そういうふうに この人の感情がそこで変わっちゃうんですね
でも原因は人 感情としては嫌な感情が生まれたんですね
嫌な人ね 前は原因は人
あ いい人やと感情が生まれたんですね
なぜ同じ原因で二つ 二種類の結果が生まれますかね
それはありえないんですね
同じ原因で二つの結果生まれることはありえない
原因に結果は一応決まってますから
そこで条件がついてくるんですね
この原因がやっぱり距離があったんだから
そういう感情が生まれて
その距離がなくなって明確に見えるところになったところで
違う感情が生まれるんだから
やっぱり条件のことも考えなくてはいけませんと
米を研いで水を入れて
釜に入れて 火を火の上にかけておけばご飯になりますよと言えば
それはそれで十分ですけど
ただそれだけでご飯にはなりませんね
どれぐらい火をかけておけば何時間ですかとかね
ということにはなります
ただ単に原因だけ揃っておけばいいやというならば
朝起きて米を研いで 水を入れて
ガスコンロにつけておいて
仕事に行くと いて 夜帰ってくると
まあ何のことなくご飯ができているということにはなりませんね
帰ってくると 家事に火事になっている結果にはなるかもしれませんだけど
ご飯のところ  そういうふうなことで考えて
やっぱり原因揃っただけではダメで
それぞれの原因にもまた条件が付け加えた方がしっかりするんじゃないかなということで
縁起論と縁起の仕方と
所縁論の仕方とかね 条件の説明という二つに分けてます
分け方はほとんどアビダルマ的で
初期仏教ではないんですね
二つに分けたことは 初期仏教経典であるのは
やっぱり一番目の原因の論なんですね
パティチサンウッパーダということなんですね
そこでこちらでこの第三番目の番号がついているところに
この この二つの差がどんなものかと説明していますけど
一番目のパッターナでは
原因というものはどういうものかと
結果というものはどういうものかと
そういう項目の説明であると
例えばAからBが生まれるというと A
というのはどういうものか
どういう特色を持っている
どういうものかと それから生まれるBがどういう特色を持っている
どういうものかと その関係のみ考えちゃうんですね
そこで二番目はパッターナになっちゃうと
この原因がどのように働きかけて結果が出しますかと
その原因の条件化 AからB生まれるのではなくて A
がこういうこういうふうにあるとBが生まれるんだと
そういうことで理解しにくい
どうしても まずAからBが生まれるんだと C
からEが生まれるんだとかね
それで原因と結果 原因と結果
いくらかはもう取ってもらう
それからAからBが生まれる場合は A
はどういうどういう条件の中でBが生まれるかと C
からEが生まれると言ったならば C
はどういう条件の中でEが生まれるんだから生まれるかと別に勉強しなくちゃいけない
そういうことだから 二番目はものすごく膨大なものになってしまっちゃうんです
うん じゃあそれで で あの簡単に説明に行きます
1番目はパティチサモッパーで悩っていうこと
縁起の仕方 縁起の仕方
まあまあとっくに皆様方覚えていると思いますけどね
まあアヴィッジャパッチャーサンカーラサンカーラパッチャーヴィンヤーナヴィンヤーナパッチャーナーマルーパナーマルーパッチャーサラヤタナサラヤタナパッチャー
ファスファッサパッチャーヴェーダナーヴェーダナーパッチャータンナータンハパッチャーウパーダーナウパーダーナパッチャーバホバハパッチャージャーティジャー
ティパッチャージャラーマラナンソーカパリデーヴァドゥッカドーマナッスパーヤーサーサンバワンティというところ
12因縁ですね だから 12因縁として
これは大体どんな仏教の宗派の世界でも一応知られているものです
経典では別に 12因縁ですよというふうには決まってないんです
その時その時の まあそれなりにまあ説明しただけで
12もある場合もあるし
10がある場合もあるし
8しかない場合もあるし
6しかない場合もあるし
その時その時項目が増えたり減ったりはしましたし
それからそれと関係なく全く違う方法でも因縁説明因果を説明したと経典もあります
ですから 因と原因と結果のことだから
かなり自由にお釈迦様は説法していたんです
うーん なんか分からないんだけど
どんどん仏教が年取っていくと
もう 12因縁に固定化してしまっちゃったんです
それでなんで固定化したんですかと自分が自分なりに考えたところで数えてみたんですね
数えてみたら やっぱりお経の数が多いんですね
12因縁の説法の場合は
だから 12しているのは少ないし
で  24もありますけど
24  23ぐらい入ってる
それは経典一つしかないんですね
6とか4とか入ってる経典もまあそれでたくさんないんですね
で 数がたくさんあるんですね
12因縁は無明から生老病死まで行ってる
国の項目の因果説はね
だから数がたくさんあるんだから
まあそこはまあ固定化してしまった可能性はあります
まあどうせそうでないと無理なんですね
例えば二三にしている経典はたった一つしかないんだから
これスッタニパータに出ているドウェターナ・ヴァッス・スッタってあるんですけど
で 日項目で丸めておく
因果説を全部喋っておく
また違う日項目を取って
それでまとめておくと
で 話し方も違うんです
考え方も違うんです その場合は
で それも面白いんだけど
それしかないんですね
経典は ですから それだけそれが因縁の話
考え方よというのはちょっと無理になってしまって
もうたくさん経典に出てくるんだから
この十二因縁が出てきちゃったんです
で ついでに皆様の勉強に役に立つということで
この十二因縁 お釈迦様が説いた立場のところはほんのちょっと理解した方がいいと思います
まあ大体役に立つのは経典の方ですから
アビダンマよりも で お釈迦様はあまり条件のことを考えないし
お釈迦様はやっぱり不思議にこのどのように因縁のことを考えるべきかという
この方程式を教えるんですね
この方程式は経典だからこの数字では出てきませんだけど
一応文章としては出てきますね
だからその文章は イマス・ミン・サティ・イダン・ホーティ
それ一つの行 次の行は
イマッサ・ウッパーダ・イダン・ウッパッジェティ
それは一つのセットで
これは番目のセットですね
一番目のセットはイマス・ミン・サティ・イダン・ホーティ
イマッサ・ウッパーダ・イダン・ウッパッジェティ
二番目のセットはイマス・ミン・アサティ・イダン・ナ・ホーティ
イマッサ・ニローダ・イダン・ニルッジェティ
それはまあ方程式ですからね
で 意味なんですけど イマス・ミン・サティ
これがある時 これがある時
イダン・ホーティ これがあると
いわゆる数字にすればAがある時Bがあると
まああるでもいいし なるでもいいんですね
イマス・ミン・サティ・イダン・ホーティ
だからAがある時Bがあると
二行目はイマッサ・ウッパーダ・イダン・ウッパッジェティ
ウッパーダというのは生まれる
生起する 現れるということなんですね
これが現れると 生まれると
これも現れる 生まれると
ですからAが生まれる時 B
が生まれる という現れ方
何 これダブっているのではないかと考えられるかもしれませんね A
がある時Bがある